suivant la tradition le lièvre à la
royale c'est un mais deux rois alliant
lièvre farce cognac qui foulera une
cuisson pendant des heures et de longue
préparation
une recette classique mais très
technique c'est pas difficile c'est très
difficile très très difficile à l'éval
royal faut le dépecer entièrement faux
le farcir avec une belle farce de lièvre
avec du foie gras de la truffe le
recoudre le refermer le cuire pendant
des heures dans un bouillon de gibier
après faire sa sauce c'est comme tout il
faut beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup de
répétitions une cuisson très lente
et puis après le travail des garnitures
qui ont offert ça sera pas la pièce
principale
mais ça va compter quand même tout
compte aujourd'hui de la difficulté
certes des produits nobles certes mais
est-ce un peu l'exception c'est quelque
chose qui est très demandé
c'est quelque chose qu'on accepte de
manger puisque c'est un kaki avec même
un supplément la carte parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne mangent qu'une
fois dans l'année
la chasse du lièvre c'est du 15 octobre
au 15 novembre
et c'est fini après il y en a plus je
veux dire c'est quelque chose
d'exception ils n'étaient que neuf à
avoir été sélectionnés pour la
compétition
et parmi eux le plus arméniens des
restaurateurs belge il s'est levé le
matin 5 heures pour être présent à
romorantin à bruxelles son lièvre à la
royale figurent à la carte de son
restaurant
la recette n'a été transmis par un ami
qui a proposé sa sur sa carte dans un
restaurant bruxellois qui s'appelle ce
tir veine il a proposé ça pendant plus
de 25 ans il est en retraite c'est un
ami c'est mon père spirituel c'est
monsieur troubat il m'a transmis sa
recette et je suis très fier depuis deux
ans proposé sans ma carte
c'est un plat d'anthologie que ces chefs
ont confectionné certains été étoilé
mais tous
ont emmené le public au septième ciel